27 people there were boys with their
cars summer jobs oh my god are you one
of them he dressed up like a clown for
them with his face paint white and red
and on his best behavior in a dark room
on the bed he'd killed them all with the
sleight of his hand running far running
fast to the dead those are the lyrics
from a song titled John Wayne Gacy jr.
by sofyan Stephens it is just one of the
countless pieces of art that have been
inspired by this terrifying serial
killer John Wayne Gacy was a businessman
and a politician to everyone around him
he was a sweet and charming man no one
in his life could have a guest that he
dressed up like Pogo the clown and
murdered teenage boys after dark the
Chicago Police Department found 27
bodies buried in his basement
they knew that his kill count though it
was at least 33 and there could be more
victims that were simply never found
this story became front-page news and
immediately captivated the nation the
fact that a killer clown truly existed
in the world struck fear into the hearts
of people everywhere believing that they
could no longer trust circus performers
around their children the story of John
Wayne Gacy has inspired writers to
create their own versions of killer
clowns including penny wise from Stephen
King as well as twisty the clown in
American Horror Story and in the
upcoming 2019 DC Comics film Joker
Joaquin Phoenix portrays the character
by copying Pogo the clown's menacing
makeup so who was the man behind the
face paints how did he get this way and
why did he go on such a murderous
rampage
[Music]
John Wayne Gacy jr. was born in Chicago
on March the 17th 1942 his father John
Stanley Gacy was a factory worker John's
father was very much a man's man who
enjoyed sports and drinking beer he
really wanted a son and he imagined
having a boy to do all of the
traditional father-son activities
together with his mother Marion was a
housewife he was very sweet and loving
to her children John and Marion named
their baby John Jr and gave him the
middle name Wayne so that he could be
named after the manly cowboy actor John
Wayne growing up the family called him
Johnny
John senior was a very strict
disciplinarian and a raging alcoholic
because of his outbursts Johnny spent
more time with his mother and sisters
John senior tried to play sports with
him in the back yard and go on weekend
fishing trips but the boy was never
really very interested he referred to
plant flowers Kirk and do traditionally
feminine activities his father was
extremely disappointed in Johnny so he
constantly called him a sissy he asked
him if he was trying to be a girl and
forbid him from doing the hobbies that
he actually enjoyed Johnny's mother
would spoil him with food in an attempt
to make up for his father's abuse and he
became overweight his parents were
constantly arguing and it would often
escalate into fights when his father
drank he would beat Johnny and his
sisters with a leather and razor strap
for many years the children would cry
out in pain but one day during a
particularly bad whipping it was like a
switch just flipped in Johnny's brain he
stopped crying and he hardly even
flinched this only made his father more
angry and he proceeded to beat him even
harder one day Johnny passed out when he
was playing with his friends he was
taken to the hospital where they
diagnosed him with a heart condition and
with that it was official John Wayne
Gacy would never be an athlete no matter
how hard his father pushed him to play
sports he could not physically handle
running without his heart just giving
out in 1954 Johnny joined the Boy Scouts
and he became good friends with a boy
called Barry Bocelli Johnny felt that he
could trust Barry with his biggest
secret
he stole a pair of panties and a bra
from his mother's bedroom when he was
alone he would dress up as a woman and
stare at himself in the mirror sometimes
he would put on lipstick and wonder if
he really should have been born a girl
it was clear that Johnnie was
questioning his gender identity in his
sexuality it must have been obvious to
the rest of his family too because John
senior would often say that he would
rather
son be dead than find out he was a
homosexual even though his father was
clearly abusive johnny was still
desperate to be the son his father
always wanted he started to date girls
and tried to have a normal life but he
was bullied in school for being
overweight and having his heart
condition it would seem that no matter
how hard he tried to suppress it John
Wayne Gacy could never fit into the
world that he was born into
[Music]
as soon as he graduated from high school
John Wayne Gacy was 18 years old and he
wanted to get as far away from his
hometown as he possibly could he moved
to the city of Springfield where he
became a shoe salesman in a department
store after work he became the assistant
precinct captain for the Democratic
Party he started dating one of his
co-workers marina Meyers her father was
wealthy and well-connected in
Springfield politics Gacy told his
friends and family that someday he
wanted to become the governor of
Illinois and maybe even the presidents
of the United States a few years later
he married Marilyn Mars but he was far
from a faithful partner on the day
Marilyn was in the hospital giving birth
to their first child John Wayne Gacy was
at a bar with one of his male co-workers
they got drunk and went back to gay C's
house and had sex just a few hours later
his first child was born
John senior came to see his new
grandchild and for the first time in
John Wayne Gacy 's life his father said
that he was proud of him John's new
father-in-law owned several KFC
restaurant franchises at 24 he left his
job selling shoes and became a manager
of one of these restaurants according to
his best friends Barry Garry wanted the
job very badly because he wanted to be
able to control people John Wayne Gacy
continued to climb the ladder with local
politics
he was always studying people around him
and trying to figure out how he could
make everyone like him he built a
full-service bar in the living room of
his house and he convinced his wife that
they needed through swingers parties
together if you're not aware this is
where couples would show up and switch
spouses for the night this was popular
back in the 1960s since everyone was
raving about the new free love movement
the gay seas were also known to host
massive orgies in their home these sex
parties made John Wayne Gacy popular
almost immediately and he became the
vice president of the local council they
also voted him as a man of the year at
the time homosexual men usually led
double lives whenever they wanted to
have gay sex they would start cruising
men would take a walk in the park or
down a road late at night waiting for
another man to approach they would have
sex and often would never see one
another again however since he was a
public figure it's possible that John
Wayne Gacy thought that it would be too
risky to have sex with any adult who
might know who he is he decided to go
after people that he felt he could
easily control he invited a
fifteen-year-old boy named Donald for
his over to his house he knew Donald
because he worked with his father who
was
senator Donald lurked up to John like a
cool older brother and he offered to let
Donald drink alcohol and see his porn
collection after the boy got drunk he
forced Donald to have oral sex with him
when he was over Gacy threatened the boy
by saying that he had connections with
the mob if he ever told anyone he would
send someone to kill him and his family
when Gacy dropped Donald for his off at
home he gave him $50 in exchange for the
boys
silence Donald for he has kept that
night a secret for a very long time that
he was never the same again in 1968 he
broke down and told his family what had
happened when he was 15 John Wayne Gacy
was arrested for sodomy he swore that he
did not do it and asked for a
lie-detector test he was convinced that
he could fool the test but he ultimately
failed when he was called out on this
lie he tried to claim that the sex with
Donald was consensual
several of the teenage boys then came
forward to say that they had been raped
by Gacy as well he was found guilty and
he was sentenced to ten years in prison
his wife divorced him and she did not
want him to see their children ever
again now this could have been the end
of it all but unfortunately Gacy used
his charm to schmooze his way into the
hearts of everyone in the prison once he
was behind bars he made friends with
other inmates as well as the guards
since he had experience working at KFC
he was able to become the head chef in
the kitchen he received a lot of praise
but knowing how to properly spice food
and he was even interviewed for a local
television program called
Christmas at Anamosa although his
father's fears though dead come true
John senior died as soon as his son went
to prison John Wayne Gacy believed that
his father he died from shame he became
so angry that he lashed out his anger on
any gay man he came into contact with
while in prison he spotted two men
having oral sex so he bashed in one of
the men's faces until it was bloody
despite being found guilty for raping
multiple boys John Wayne Gacy was
released after just 16 months on good
behavior
he returned to Cook County where he
lived with his mother people in his
hometown they didn't know about his
conviction and they just remembered him
as a young and innocent boy a fat kid
with a heart condition so it was very
easy for him to get a fresh start in
life he found a job as a short-order
cook and he saved up his money by
working overtime once he had enough
money he started a construction company
called PDM contractors he also jumps
back into local politics newly divorced
Gary started dating a woman that he knew
from high school called Carol Hoff she
was a divorcee with two daughters and
she was struggling to make it on welfare
strong Wayne Gacy was great around kids
and a steady job and was also ambitious
from Carol's perspective he was a catch
and his daughter started calling daddy
right away he admitted to Carol that he
was bisexual but he never told her about
his time in jail she accepted him for
who he was and in that moment he had
everything but he was never satisfied
in fact he felt that he'd been in prison
so long his craving to have sex with
teenage boys had only been amplified one
night John Wayne Gacy was hanging out at
the Greyhound bus station he spotted a
16 year olds name's Tim McCoy who was
traveling during Christmas time and had
a brief layover in Chicago
Gacy started flirting with him and
offered to show him around the city Tim
must have assumed that this was just a
typical cruising fling they had sex but
Gacy was angry at himself for giving in
to his homosexuality he impulsively
grabbed a kitchen knife and stabbed him
in the chest multiple times he buried
the boy in the dirt basement crawlspace
underneath his house Tim's parents never
saw him for Christmas indeed it would be
years before they found out about the
fate of their son John Wayne Gacy got
married to Carol seven months later and
she moved into the house with her
daughters his new wife would have no
idea that she was moving into a house
where the remains of a young boy were
buried right below her feet John Wayne
Gacy continued to suppress his
homosexual urges instead of putting on
lipstick though he started to paint his
face in pound makeup normally clowns
have friendly curved features but Gacy
painted on sharp harsh edges he called
himself a Pogo the clown and started
showing up at the local hospital to do
magic tricks for the children who were
sick when he was Pogo he could do all
the things that John was not allowed to
do this escalated to giving in to his
indulgences again burying his victims in
the basement John's wife Carol was
concerned because she could tell that
his personality had drastically changed
after he began to play Pogo John refused
to have sex with her and he made her
feel worthless they filed for divorce in
1975 when he was 33 years old
after the
he was free to hunt teenage boys as
often as he wanted he would drive around
town dressed in his full clown makeup if
he saw her boy walking alone at night he
would hold up a gun and force them into
the car he would rape and stab them
before burying them again in the
basement burying all of those bodies it
was hard work so he brought in one of
his new employees David kram to dig
holes in the basement he claims that he
needed to add new piping hams of the
house but he was under strict orders to
avoid certain areas of the basement
David had no idea that John Wayne Gacy
was forcing him to dig his own grave
crime was from out of town and he told
Gacy that he was looking for new
apartments Gacy offer to rents him one
of the bedrooms of his house in exchange
for labor one night though Pogo the
clown walked through the door and David
kram was confused John was already drunk
and his makeup was sliding off his face
he wasn't acting like John any more he
spoke in a nasally high-pitched voice
like a clown and asked David if he
wanted a mai tai
David laughed and assumed that this was
some kind of joke so he agreed to drinks
Coco asked if he would like to see a
magic trick as he put handcuffs on
David's wrists he dangled the key in
front of him giggling like a child Pogo
the clown then started poking David
saying does this get you mad what about
this ha ha David then threatened to
punch him if he didn't stop but Gacy
never broke character in the middle of a
sentence Pogo started growling and
barking like a dog then he started
saying in a sing-songy voice I'm going
to rape you over and over he tried to
force David down onto the floor
attempting to rip off his pants
David kicked Gacy as hard as he could
and the clown fell to the floor
dropping the key to the handcuffs David
was able to escape from the house but he
never spoke a word of this incident to
anyone until many years later others
though they wouldn't be so lucky to
escape
[Music]
John Wayne Gacy seized last known victim
was a 15 year old named Robert piste who
worked at a Des Plaines pharmacy Gacy
had spotted the boy in a previous
shopping trend so he showed up at the
pharmacy asking to speak to the owner
he offered to renovate their pharmacy
and casually asked if he you have any
teenage boys who are looking for a job
because he was willing to pay five
dollars an hour for construction work
Robert peaced took the bait this was
double what he made at the pharmacy so
he called up Casey's company to apply
later and as he left the house peace
mother asked him where he was going he
said some contractor wants to talk to me
about a job and he left his mother never
saw her son again at this point Gacy had
run out of room in his basement there
were already 27 corpses beneath his
house so Pogo the clown he had to dump
Roberts body in the river
when the police found Roberts body it
was easy for them to take testimonies
and connect the dots
they approached John Wayne Gacy but he
was confident that he would not be
caught he even invited the investigators
over to his house for dinner and drinks
one of the officials could smell the
stench of rotting corpses coming up
through the air vents they came back
with another warrants and uncovered the
bodies of the teenage boys in the
basement when John Wayne Gacy was
brought into custody the police were
preparing to take his mug shot they were
asking him basic information like his
name and his birthdate and officer asked
him where were you born
Gacy replied out of chaos he started to
laugh at his own joke the camera flashed
at that very moment capturing the image
of a murderer who was truly pleased with
himself when they found the bodies Gacy
knew that he was done he quickly claims
that he had multiple personality
disorder and that he had no control over
go the clown did but clearly he had
planned rob beast's murder for a long
time after a psychological evaluation it
was obvious to anyone that he was just
trying to play insanity but that he
seemed to be fully aware of what he was
doing during his trial Gacy had the best
defense team anyone could ask for
because of his ties to local government
when he received the death penalty he
actually congratulated his team as this
was the result he wanted all along while
in prison John Wayne Gacy began to draw
pictures of clowns and sold his artwork
during every interview he did behind
bars Gacy claimed that he was innocent
and refused to take blame for any of his
actions at one point even decided to
write a book where he claimed that the
bodies in his basement were part of a
set
to ruin his political career May the
10th 1994 was the day of his execution
crowds of people stood outside the
prison chanting kill him
kill him holding up signs when it was
announced that he had died from lethal
injection
the crowds cheered immediately following
his death forensic psychologists
dissected KC's body and removed his
brain they wanted to see if there were
any abnormalities they might give them
some kind of clue as to why he'd become
a serial killer but there was nothing to
be found even to this day experts are
still debating on how to diagnose John
Wayne Gacy he has been called a
sociopath the psychopath a paranoid
schizophrenic and some have agreed with
his self diagnosis of dissociative
identity disorder what we know for sure
though is that if it were not for all
the shame he endured all his life these
killings may never have happened in the
first place so I hope you found that
video interesting if you did give us a
thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe also if you're looking for
something else to watch right now why
not check out some videos from our
archives or why not check out my other
channel cool today I found out you'll
find a link to that below and as always
thank you for watching